babysitters everyone
good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the present
public i welcome you to this meeting of
the council
uh before we start we have a few basic
um
instructions to go through now if a fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
officers via the stairs either through
the security doors to my right or
opposite the lifts in the fire please do
not use the lifts please assemble in
halle square on the green
officers will assist you and advise
where it is deemed safe to return to
this chamber
now with respect to filming of the
meeting
i would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
area may have their image captured
i urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present does anyone intend to film a
meeting
i can see one hand indicated so we do
have filming
is there two we've got two hands
thank you
right since it's a yes any member of the
public objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to leave the meeting
does anyone wish to leave
it would seem not
now any filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the present public from the
meeting
there is a restriction on the use of
mobile phones with everyone present
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and they are
not used to make or receive phone calls
whilst in this the meetings in progress
i in fact don't even bring my phone with
me
so there we are
members moving on to agenda item one
apologies for absence now i've received
apologies from councillor boyd
councillor huxley and councillor shonk
and i must advise that councillors bob
and jill bayford are away for private
reasons and those who know uh will send
their best wishes on i'm sure are there
any other apologies for absence
apologies from councillor green
liz green
councillor liz greene thank you
councillor curry you indicated
that that was your um do i have any uh
counselor piper
thank you chair council john dennis is
unwell councillor john day do i have any
other apologies for absence
i don't seem to thank you very much
agenda item two declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interests
this evening
and i don't see any
indicated
so right moving straight on to the
purpose of our meeting this evening our
single agenda item
the auditor statutory recommendations
issued under section 24 ok under the
local gov audit and accountability act
of 2014.
i call upon the leader councillor ashby
thank you chair
i firstly would like to thank sarah iron
manga and her team for the diligent work
in the production of the report and
recommendations by examining the
governance and financial sustainability
at the council
when i was elected i made it clear that
good governance is the cornerstone of
effective local government
it is only right and proper that
councils have the opportunity to ask
questions of the external auditor agree
to its recommendations and to be part of
the process
i am pleased that by identifying areas
of concern and making the
recommendations of actions to be taken
the agreement tonight will enable the
first steps towards us building a sound
future for this council
therefore
i ask members to support the proposal of
firstly agree the recommendations are
set out in the report from grant
thornton secondly to agree the actions
which grant thornton have proposed to
include updates at the various stages of
the full council
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed leader uh do
you have a secondary
counselor
thank you very much
i call upon in
now mr dossett the head of local
government for grant thornton and miss
einmonger director of audit at grant
thornton to present their report i
believe mr dosage you're going to make
the first presentation
thank you chairman and good evening
members um sarah will shortly take you
through the report but i just wanted to
say
uh some things to start with first of
all
statutory recommendations are not common
um
in the past couple of years we've seen
uh in total uh for
public interest reports which is a sort
of higher level version as it were
and um seven
uh statutory recommendation reports
issued so it's a relatively rare thing i
have to say it's becoming less rare
there are a number of issues at a number
of councils that have
given rise to these types of reports in
the last couple of years
but they are very important
um
secondly
statutory recommendations will require a
response
and accountability from the council as a
whole hence presenting the report
to full council and therefore all
members will both hear
what sarah's got to say and and the
recommendations
and obviously be part of owning the
action this is not a individual thing
this is a collective council
responsibility
thirdly i would point out the
consequences of inaction
so if we are not satisfied with progress
after a reasonable period of time
we will have to consider what are the
next steps from our point of view
now that's something we have to consider
and give due consideration to the at the
time
but
the more obvious next step would be
public interest report
and any council who's received the
public interest report would say they
really don't want to
to receive one of those ever again
and and finally just for clarity for
members once
we've gone through the process of
presenting the report and their members
are asking us questions
um we will not be answering questions
about individuals we'll be answering
questions about the report and the
recommendations that we made and why
we've made them et cetera et cetera but
just for clarity we will not be
answering questions about individuals so
i will now hand over to sarah who will
take you through the report
thank you paul thank you very much mr
dosset um
thank you chair
um as paul has said this is an unusual
situation and it reflects a complex and
sensitive set of circumstances
our report reflects our view of the
situation
and whilst we're not here to discuss
individuals we do want to talk to you
talk to you about the arrangements
so now that i have the microphone
in the correct place uh all i was saying
was it's an unusual set of circumstances
um and our report reflects our view of
the situation
so what
what is clear to us is that the
arrangements that you have in place to
respond to alleged whistleblowing
grievances and disciplinary procedures
are not adequate
and this is shown through the impact in
terms of the length of time matters are
taken to resolve
and the financial cost to resolve those
matters
this started with the management of an
initial allegation which was considered
by the general purposes committee in
2019
but the response to that initial
allegation drew in various senior
officers and the situation has continued
for an extended period of time
and the council's governance
arrangements have not been sufficient to
manage that situation in a timely manner
and if you can see on page three where
we talk about some of those issues so
the failure to adopt promptly the
governance principles of the joint
negotiating committee for chief officers
there is an argument that if those those
were issued in 2015 if the council had
adopted them by the time the issues
arose in 2019 you would have had a
framework to deal with this
um
there are
there are a number of whistleblowing
cases grievance and disciplinary cases
and there is a need to
deal with those out the outcomes of
those promptly and systematically
and the process for managing those
because it wasn't done in a systematic
way led to a number of escalations
and again when the general purposes
committee considered matters
on occasions there was a lack of clarity
around the action and then that led to
further escalation
there are there have been situations
where there have been perceived and
actual conflicts of interest
and by not addressing those that's added
to further tension and further
escalation
and and as the situation developed it
brought as i say it brought in senior
officers and members needed to have been
involved at an earlier stage because of
the
seniority of the officers drawn into the
process
you did establish
an idsc an investigatory disciplinary
subcommittee in 2020 and that
progress matters to a certain extent but
i think as the situation developed what
has happened is a range of reports and
reviews were commissioned from
independent reviewers and i'm mentioning
these on page four that we've had access
to eight such reports
um
whilst the reports might raise concern
about conduct of individuals our concern
is about how the council has responded
to the reports
we would have expected clear action to
be taken in response to externally
commissioned reports
and in our view effort has effort was
directed towards discrediting those
reports for procedural matters rather
than focusing on the substance of the
matters in the report
and so
this is yeah there's an example of a
whistleblowing allegation which was uh
whilst it was deemed not to meet the
definition of a whistleblowing
allegation what would expect is for you
to use a council to understand
the substance of the matter even if it
doesn't meet the technicality of a
whistleblowing
so when we step back and look at all of
the reports collectively
we're of the view that the council's
response has not been adequate
and there are some there are some
significant consequences
of that and we we set those out on page
five so
the financial cost both in terms of the
um
the amount you've had to spend
commissioning reviews responding to them
as well as the potential
additional costs if you don't deal with
these matters properly um then
employment tribunals may levy fines on
you for a remedy
those are significant we talk about uh
in the in the paper around your
financial position being fragile
um and
we said in our um we said in our
previous uh reports that there's very
little head room to cope with any
further cost pressures
well this has been a cost pressure that
you have the
as a result of these matters there are
cost pressures additional ones you need
to be responding to
one of the other consequences is there's
been an awful lot of time used by senior
officers and members
trying to deal with these matters and
those ma that time and that energy needs
to be directed towards the functions and
delivering the services of thanoc
council
because this has gone on for so long
there's this perception that the
management culture
is not going to respond to
concerns now
culture is difficult to find perception
is difficult to define but this has come
through
in in uh in the work that we've done
and importantly i think your duty of
care as a council to your officers
hasn't has been compromised because it
has taken a long time to deal with this
and individuals have suffered
significant reputation damage because
there have been leaks of some of the
information and as an employer of the
people
of the people
involved that duty of care is not there
so what we are saying is the situation
at planet does not represent good
governance we consider urgent action as
needed to stabilize the situation and to
rebuild trust in the council
from a residence from an offices and
from a member's perspective
so we have set out four recommendations
which we consider will address the
situation and move you as a council
forward
and those are set out in the report so
just to talk through
um the first couple on page seven
we are saying that we we want a
systematic review of all cases
outstanding so there is a risk
assessment about what the options to
resolve all those outstanding cases are
we are saying an experienced independent
monitoring officer because we
there are
lots of views whether they're about real
and perceived conflicts of interest so
somebody that you can all agree is
independent of you looking at this we
have term we've suggested an experienced
monitoring officer because that's a term
that is commonly understood within local
government
so there's a systematic review there's
also just an assessment of where that
some of those outstanding cases are and
what your plan of action to address them
is
and as part of that i think it's really
important to assess all those different
reports that have come in and learn and
create a lessons learned
document that you can all
ensure that this is not a situation that
repeats
the second recommendation is about the
idsc process and
and progress is ongoing with that on the
next page we talk about the financial
sustainability and i've mentioned that
your it's a fragile
space
spending on the matters in our report
has added further challenge to your
financial gap and as a council you are
going to need to address that gap
as part of setting your budget and a
future medium-term financial strategy
our fourth recommendation is
is as we've worked through this it's
clear to us there's not always a shared
understanding of where officers and
member responsibilities lie we believe
you need to be very clear all of you on
that shared understanding
and that you are clear which matters sit
where so that you can rebuild that trust
for everybody around both members
officers and residents
that's all i was proposing to say on
that
and we will take questions chair
yes thank you very much indeed miss iron
manga now members will have the
opportunity to ask the external auditors
questions when asking questions would
members please refrain from referencing
individuals and please be aware that the
auditors will not be able to comment on
individual cases now i propose to break
this down such that um as mr munger has
indicated we take questions first before
moving on to debate um in the usual
manner so
questions please first members
council auburn
thank you chair um it's something that
uh mr dossett said
in in his opening um it was in relation
to
uh a reasonable time
to uh for the for these actions to be
implemented
could you define what you consider to be
a reasonable time thank you
thank you councillor alban mr dosset
thank you chairman um
a reasonable time uh obviously you have
to develop an action plan and start to
deliver it so we're not talking about
weeks or even a couple of months but i
would expect
within a six month period that
substantive progress has been made i
mean that's not a cut-off point but you
know if we were looking at this in in
may 2022 i'd expect substantial progress
to have been made
thank you casa ghana
thank you
um
yeah well firstly thank you sarah and
the team
um for
for the work you've done producing this
comprehensive report
which we have here this evening i've got
a single question now because the other
one council auburn has asked
but this question i'd like to ask is in
the context of some of the details that
you've mentioned
um
that are captured in the body of the
report
the details that include the catalogue
of failures in the council's governance
process
the serious breakdown in relationships
between senior officers over the last
few years and most importantly as you
mentioned the findings in the eight
separate independently produced reports
you've examined
um into the number of specific
whistleblowing grievance and
disciplinary cases
these reports i think as you've said as
well as identifying clear evidence of
bullying of whistleblowers and of
whistleblowers being subject to
unwarranted discipline reaction
themselves
also contained recommendations that were
either misinterpreted ignored or
discredited
and they also confirmed that although
the council has appropriate policies and
procedures for dealing with grievances
and staff performance issues on a number
of occasions these were not adhered to
by senior officers so my question is
while i agree with the actions outlined
in the report and look forward to the
independent monitoring officer being
appointed as soon as possible to get on
with the job what can we do in the
meantime to make sure that any existing
or new grievance and whistleblowing
cases are dealt with appropriately
rather than in the manner you've
identified they've been dealt with over
the last few years
thank you
thank you councillor ghana uh mr dossett
so um i will start with answering some
of these questions my colleague uh
here's who apologies we didn't
introduced uh tom foster did some of the
work with me so at points we may need to
answer together
so
i think the there are matters that your
reports have come through and the
reports have all gone to the idsc
i think it's important that there is a
process that is followed and you're
going to need um
you're going to need assurance that the
process is being systematically followed
going forward from here
i think our recommendation about the
monitoring officer
reviewing everything that is there
because in a large organization there
will always be some elements of
complaints and we need that systematic
assessment of both
is there an issue
because just because someone makes an
allegation doesn't necessarily make that
allegation an issue
is there an issue
what is what is the best way of
resolving that and being proactive in
resolving those
so
there's the historic piece which they
can collate that i think you need to be
really clear on a set of and this
monitoring officer may well help you
with that about what your process should
be and how to get assurance on it in an
in a
in a council without these issues you
would have these you'd have arrangements
set up and perhaps someone like internal
audit might review them and say yes
they're working
as we expected
you may want some greater assurance on
that because of the historic issues
thank you miss eye manga yes
thank you councillor ghana councillor
austin
thank you chair and thank you ms zion
bug for your report
um
i'm a new counselor i've only been in
the the role for six months but in a
long period of uh work in the public
sector i've rarely come across such a
shocking catalogue of problems as we
have here and i hold us as counselors
responsible for it we should have
created a better governance
environment and it's up to us to do
something about it so i'm thoroughly in
support of your recommendations
the thing i wanted to ask
was about the scope of the independent
monitoring officers uh work
with us
most particularly i'm thinking about the
area around shared understanding about
members and officers roles and the
building up of trust
i've
never come across a council
where
elected members are held at arm's length
from decision making as much as happens
in this council i don't mean just
i don't mean just decision making with
regard to personnel issues which
obviously are are
a different matter but more generally
and this in my view
stems from decisions taken by our
predecessor council between 2015 and
2019.
please
move on to debate after we changed our
constitution and our member officer
protocol and our scheme of delegation
is there scope
for the independent monitoring officer
to look at those matters because i am
concerned that without a fundamental
review of these issues we're not
actually going to be able to move
forward thank you
thank you very much miss armanga so so
thank you uh for summarizing i think our
view would be that it is up to the to
everyone in this room the councillors in
this room to ensure that you move
forward with this situation
um in regards to the specifics i think
it isn't unusual for councils for
members and officers not to necessarily
agree
where the line is between what's an
officer and a member responsibility i
think what we're saying what we are
saying is that we have had
so much correspondence where that it's
clear that you do not all have a shared
understanding of that
we are not saying whether it's right or
wrong we are saying you need to have a
shared understanding so that you can all
function both officers and members you
all need to be clear on that
i think in terms of the way you've
chosen to do your constitution that is
not something that is for me to speak to
that is something that you as your
democratic process respond to
thank you very much for that do i have
counselor keen i think indicated yes
thank you
um just a short question on the first
recommendation you've got about the
independent monitoring officer reporting
to the general purposes committee given
our shared responsibility as councillors
why is it not coming straight back to
full council
thank you hunger
um yes so
as a council you may you will want
progress against all of these
recommendations coming back to you
because it's about the independent
monitoring of so going through
individual cases if there are actions
that need to be taken against those
individual cases that would normally go
to the general purposes committee to go
through that detail
and so that's why we were suggesting
that what you as a council may want is
is maybe some headline figures from the
monitoring officer we've looked at this
many this many are going here so you
know what the progress is but in terms
of the detail then that needs to sit
where you if you're going through an
individual person's case that needs to
sit in the right place within your
constitution
thank you for that country gates
thank you very much for the reports um
i've just got three questions um
the first is you've highlighted that um
there's been a failure to manage whisher
blair in cases grievances and
disciplinary cases and outcomes promptly
and systematically
um in regards to the definition the word
systematically sorry to get into
definitions um does that mean that
certain cases weren't followed
chronologically
my second question is
um you've seen you mentioned
discrediting external reports i'm just
wondering
whether this is
a common situation found amongst
councils or whether this is actually
quite
um how serious is kind of that kind of
um situation um and lastly just on the
first recommendation and the external
monitoring officer
um
you're saying that they can
they can commission
they can look at external commission
reports and any other appropriate
evidence i'm just wondering with the
any other appropriate evidence can they
carry out um interviews with members and
officers
so that there's my three questions
thanks
thank you very much counselors
um mr monkey you've got three questions
um thank you so when we say
systematically
we have got examples where things were
not done in a chronological order now
there may if you do us if you do a very
detailed risk assessment you may need to
do things out of chronological order but
you need to have very clear systems
about how you make that risk assessment
and the choices you're making as to why
you are doing something in chronological
order so um
yeah in terms of uh discrediting
external reports i would say
that i find that very unusual in my
experience of local government um
the reality of local government is
um it is done too by a range of things
um and there's all sorts of regulators
and checkers who will do reports some
some invited some imposed
um it's very unusual whatever
members or officers think about these
reports to have a process of
discrediting them so i would normally
expect councils to accept reports
and move forward in the appropriate way
to address the recommendations such
reports make
and i didn't quite get the full detail
of your third question
so my third question just about the
external monitoring officer being hired
are they going to be able um as part of
gathering any other appropriate evidence
to be able to carry out interviews with
officers and members
um so one of the reasons we've set an
experience independent monitoring
officer is so that they can
bring their experience to bear of what
needs to be done in an individual
situation
um i don't think we would want to
limit their scope because they need to
follow what evidence is there
if they're following up individual cases
they are going to need to interview
officers because that would be part of
it
and i think the involvement of members
is something that i think we all need to
think carefully
through about where a member's role fits
in in terms of their actual
investigation because the recommendation
as written is going through the cases
that are there and being really clear
about those so unless any of those
involved members are not
what we had envisaged it may be
something different that you're looking
for
thank you very much
thank you very much i have uh counsellor
grink
sorry about that
thank you very much
uh i i would like to thank sorry i'll
get my glasses on i would like to thank
sarah iron monger of grant thornton for
the thorough clear well evidenced and
concise report but one i found a
harrowing read for obvious reasons both
in terms of human suffering and the
waste of financial spending which we can
really afford i've got four questions
and i will get their police chair
i'm i'm particularly concerned about
that despite eight previous reports by
six external independent reviewers
commissioned and paid for by us covering
the last two and a half years there was
clearly no real
real effort or attempt made to address
the serious issues
indeed they were allowed to escalate
instead of taking action as the report
says to address the substances the subs
the substance of the findings
it also appears further opportunities
were sadly missed in july when grant
thornton wrote to the council raising
concerns in private whilst not
diminishing the human suffering this
ongoing situation must have caused and
is still causing i cannot help but be
shocked by the staggering amount of
council tax payers money that has been
wasted as a direct consequence of both
the longevity and a failure to act
decisively and effectively according to
repeated external warnings we may agree
with you could we have the questions
as a result i welcome the
recommendations made under section 24
schedule 7 of the local audit and
accountability act 2014
things have to change and i now feel
we've reached a critical mass of support
my questions are given the failure to
act over the last two and a half years
how can we therefore be certain that
this report will result in issues in the
issues highlighted being addressed
two the four areas of recommendations
set out clear objectives with two areas
falling under the responsibility of the
leader and the ceo with senior officers
mentioned throughout this report is this
not a conflict of interest and are we
simply not allowing the same repeated
pattern of behavior to continue
how will this potential conflict of
interest be safeguarded against question
three as an elected member i remain
frustrated about the lack of clarity
between officers and members
responsibilities
will the recommendations in this report
therefore facilitate constructive input
constructive input and concerns from
elected members and and residents
question four
we do not presently have a 151 officer
sadly would this be a good opportunity
to bring in an experienced and
independent 151 officer as we are doing
with the 141 officer to lead on the
financial recommendations giving us the
critical nature of these thank you
thank you uh miss iron man
so in response to your first question
about progress um as as my colleague
said we will be keeping an eye on
progress and if we deem that the the
progress is insufficient then we would
have to consider what action we need to
take next
um
what we are
it is unusual for us to have to
escalate
but we have that ability
what i would um what i would hope is at
the end of this that you you do work on
an action plan and that you all take
responsibility for making sure there is
progress on that action plan that is
within the council's ability to respond
to so so that will be where that
progress is
in terms of the response about whether
it's the leader and the chief exec this
is about being really clear that the
leader is the is the
leader of you as elected members the
chief exec officer is the head of paid
service
both those both those roles are vital
for the running of the council and they
need to work together um and therefore
it needs to as as i said it needs to be
rebuilding the trust of everybody
um and therefore both need to agree
and if there's no agreement
then i think that would be something
that would concern us significantly
the elected
[Applause]
the lack of clarity around where elected
member roles and officers sits is very
much what that fourth recommendation is
about and you would need to have
constructive conversations involving
everybody to reach a common
understanding of it and i think as i
said earlier it's not uncommon for that
not to be entirely clear at certain
authorities but a lot of effort goes
into making that that that shared
understanding clear so the frustration
that some of you are expressing has got
has got an ability to be worked through
in terms of your section 151 officer i
think
yes you don't have you have an acting
151 officer
i think in terms of the actual
recommendation here it's about being
really clear about what plans to address
the financial
additional financial pressure it is not
quite as sensitive as the other issues
that are there which is why we suggested
that the 151 and the cabinet portfolio
holder can be it is for the council to
decide who you get to do that
thank you very much indeed um councillor
linda piper
thank you chair
thank you for your report sarah um
go into the first recommendation
commission and experienced independent
monitoring officer from a large local
authority and i'm sure all of us here
would do agree with that but then you
also said that it needs to be a monitor
independent monitoring officer that we
all agree to a point
so
are there any guidelines how we can all
put our input in to the suitability of
this
independent monitoring officer
thank you
thank you councillor piper mr munger
thank you so the responsibility sits
with the leader and the chief exec as
per my recommendation i think the you
can
you can have your views with the leader
who will be the person representing all
the elected members
the chief exec will
have
will presumably take responses from any
officers who want to have a view on that
i think the key here is that is that you
can agree that the person who is brought
in
is independent who doesn't have a
history of working with you who has not
been involved in any of these details
before
[Music]
excuse me
look we are trying to run a meeting here
to achieve a result this evening
barracking is not going to help us in
that respect so can we please have some
quiet while we carry on with proceedings
thank you
we consider the leader has the the
stature the leader of any council should
have the stature to be able to have that
conversation and represent your views
because you have elected that person as
your leader
thank you very much councillor ashby
thank you chair um i'd just like to
assure members as your elected leader
that i will
ensure
that this report is carried out in the
correct manner and the selection of the
monitoring officer is done
the independent monitoring officer is
done in the correct manner and it will
be followed through as you all know that
i stand very high
on the on the platform of governance and
um i just want to reassure you um
councillor wing but all councillors that
this will be dealt with and we will see
the right results and we will come out
the other side and have a council where
we can all be proud of and work with
thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
ashby you're going to say just sorry um
and i'd like to assure members that i
have every confidence in our acting 151
officer and i hope that you will also
support him in that in the role he's
he's actually got a big heavy workload
on but he's more than capable of
carrying out the role that we are asking
him to do so i'd ask members to support
that as well
thank you very much indeed councillor
ashby and i think that launches this
nicely into debate if
members would like to get involved do i
have somebody who would like to
counselor everett
thank you joe i'm going to stand up we
seem not to be standing up this evening
i think perhaps we've been in front of
our computer screens for too long we've
forgotten the practice of standing up
um i'd also like to thank the external
auditor for her recommendations and the
work that she's done on the council's
behalf
i fully support her recommendations on
behalf of the labor group and i want to
be clear that i absolutely recognize the
narrative set out in the background
notes and the need for section 24 notice
it is a shocking narrative but sadly it
is not a shock to those who have been
exposed to the events of the last two
years at first hand
all of us will recognize that what he
describes is a grotesque waste of public
money and both officer remember time and
it should not have happened
i think it's probably better to wait for
the lessons learnt report from an
independent monitoring officer before we
try to explore in any detail how it did
come about
but i will say that the council's lack
of adopted policies to manage grievances
and disciplinary allegations against
between the statutory officers including
a lack of clarity about the role of
elected members was indeed a major
factor
whether it was councillor bayford as
leader before me or during my own tenure
trying to navigate the situation that we
found ourselves in without that clarity
and with all the people that you would
normally rely on to advise you
conflicted was extremely challenging
that is one reason that the council
incurred such substantial legal expenses
the other was the sheer complexity of
matters that were already in trade by
october 2019
but these matters were not caused by
members and indeed this has never been a
matter of party politics
our responsibility tonight is to support
the recommendations and then to take on
board the findings of the external
monitoring officer to ensure that we can
never be in the same situation again
thank you
thank you very much indeed cancer
everett and i think that does
encapsulate very well exactly the
position we need to take this evening
councillor piper
thank you mr chairman
much of what
any of us will say this evening
uh is i'm sure already well understood
but i think it is important that for the
benefit of
the public who are not
uh imminently
party to what we're doing that these
things are set out
the decision taken by grant thornton
we've already had some hints about it to
issue this report under section 24
schedule 7 of the local audit and
accountability act is clearly not one
they've taken lightly
and we have now this evening been
advised they have additional powers to
issue a public interest report if our
response is considered ineffective
such a public interest report was issued
in croydon this time last year and in
nottingham in august 2020 these are just
as mr dosset indicated very serious
matters and we shouldn't shy away from
them
clearly as a body of public servants we
simply have to accept these
recommendations
chairman we have the background reasons
that led to these recommendations and we
have to admit it is a damning report of
failures of governments and we have to
take it on the chin
though the bulk of the criticisms are
detailed on pages three and four
it should be noted that elected members
of this council do not escape criticism
entirely
on page six
the position described i quote the
position described represents a failure
of governance with and the second
sentence is members not taking effective
action early in some instances
not an isolated incident but in
instances plural
we should have taken action in the past
and we did not
chairman we have not had an opportunity
as a body of elected representatives to
discuss this report and decide that our
response to it i'm not talking about the
council as a complete body i'm talking
about the council in terms of elected
members so we can genuinely voice our
concerns
all of which begs the question
are we
the elected members in danger of being
muzzled in our response to this report
how are we to know if this report will
be effective enough to head off a public
interest report or even court action as
a worst case scenario
for self-evident legal reasons we cannot
identify individuals in this public
forum so when our mayor asked we going
to be able to discuss these matters
are we to assume mr chairman that the
appointment of the independent
monitoring officer will allow these
background issues to be properly
investigated including why members did
not act or felt they could not act
to so that we then
can have an effective contribution to
any action plan that may be implemented
if we are to wait for their contribution
and i think we should
then clearly will not be able to
implement final recommendation
strategies during november 2021 as is
detailed on the last page of the report
it seems to me there may be more than a
little temptation to skip to the cure
before adequately and thoroughly
diagnosing the illness
grant thornton have supplied this report
using this act which has the word
accountability in it and i would like
some guidance please
surely it cannot be that the word
accountability
only applies to figures and money
any more than the word governance does
because if that were true this report
would only concentrate on money figures
and balance sheets and clearly it does a
great deal more than that
accountability must surely include
responsibility for the failings and a
need to hold people to account
we have seen the public's condemnation
of those responsible for the failings at
southern water
in this area in which we live
and we are now seeing public outrage at
the failings in their council here at
tdc
we have to get this right
because the public do have every right i
believe to hold this council to account
for this damning report
and sadly for many of us who are elected
members
it may well be that the election system
that approaches in a little over a
year's time
that the public through their
frustration
may just choose to suck the members
if they feel they have no other voice
and no other way to complain about
what's going on
thank you mr chairman
thank you very much indeed counselor
piper i don't think we can preempt uh
exactly the intentions of the report in
the action resulting therein but perhaps
sir i'm our manga would like to comment
um in terms of accountability yes you're
right it covers more than just finances
and the external audit role includes
looking at value for money arrangements
which includes governance which is where
this work comes through
from and i think
you're right to raise the point that the
electorate will
will
will take a view on the progress that
you make and the accountability i think
you have to you have to see what the
situation is once that systematic review
has gone through of all the cases
because it is not possible to
extrapolate from one the the one of two
or handful of cases we have looked at
we are saying the situation is not right
for the council and the council needs to
move forward we are not saying
what you should do about any individual
because that is not there is not
sufficient evidence to tell you that
thank you very much indeed for that do i
have another speaker
i don't seem to can we
ah sorry country gates
yeah i'm just um trying to follow up on
what
um mission munger told me earlier about
um
appropriate evidence and obviously that
we've been speaking about member
involvement tonight
and i'm just concerned about whether
this
independent monitoring office officer
can conduct interviews with both
officers and members and i did get the
impression that
um members weren't going to be
interviewed as part of the process so
from from my side i think it's important
to have that ability
for this for independent monitor after
to
uh potentially interview both officers
and members
so
so from my side i think
i'd like to propose an amendment where
we
um we include interviews
as part of the third bullet point on the
first item on page seven
um to include interviews with any
officers and members where appropriate
um because i think
from what we've seen tonight members
need to take more responsibility if
maybe there is
um a chance for us to have our voices
heard where appropriate where
appropriate from that independent
demands
i think it's important it's done
this serves no purpose your elected
representatives are addressing the
issues there's no need to turn this into
some sort of uh barracking fight
so thank you very much councillor yates
country austin
when i second councillor yates's
proposal um if we are going to take
responsibility
we have to have direct contact with with
the independent monitoring so i don't
mean every individual counselor but
there has to be that facility
and it's very difficult for us to take
responsibility given our current
constitution it it is we are in a
situation where
sensitive decisions are taken
on the council's behalf and cabinet find
out about them afterwards we're in a
situation where a member of this council
has had to
submit a freedom of information request
in order to find out what her own
council is doing in her own ward this is
not acceptable we have to have a means
by which members can
put input into this process and at the
moment we can't see a way to find that
thank you
thank you very much today counselor
awesome i mean the thing about this is
we're making an addition i did actually
feel in my reading of the report that
that was covered however i can turn to
miss austin to ask if that would be
appropriate addition to the
[Music]
sorry i'm recommendations miss alabama
got mixed up there
sorry i'll chairman i'll take that
question just just for clarity
our report
is our report so we we we don't amend
our recommendations they are our
recommendations of course how
the council chooses to take things
forward in the context of the points
raised is for the council to decide
what i would say
is i would expect if you appointed the
right caliber
of independent monitoring officer
these would this would be someone with
vast experience of dealing with these
types of matters and dealing with
members
i would expect
them to take a balanced view on who they
spoke to
and how they took on board
the communication from that person
whether members or officers so i would
expect them to make that judgment
i don't think it's about having
rules in place that say they must speak
to x number of councillors or officers
i'd expect an independent strong monitor
officer to speak
to um
counsellors as a pope and it's perfectly
reasonable for counselors to ask to
speak to the monetary officer about
matters of concern i think there has to
be a very very clear distinction though
between
broader matters of constitutional and
other concern and individual cases
because that is not
for members to be involved in
but
it is for members to engage with
a strong independent monitoring officer
role so that's that would be my view
cancer ashby
thank you chair um
i think
being too prescriptive with sub
proposals is probably counterproductive
um on the basis that
if you say if you start to set
parameters around it then that's
somewhat restricting the monitoring
officer
the independent monitoring officer i
would rather
that um it is understood and i and i
believe this this will be acceptable
that in the
plan project that the monitoring or
independent monitoring officer is given
absolutely free reigns with absolutely
anything and that will be certainly
something that i will be putting in
the plan as i see it and i can see no
reason why that wouldn't be the way that
it goes forward so rather than having
proposals that make it restrictive which
i think would be counterproductive
that is understood here and now and
agreed that this
independent monitoring officer apart
from obviously having the um
the
experience of being able to come in and
deal with this particular special
project as we'd like to think it to be
that they would have free reign to go
absolutely anywhere they want to and i
can't see any reason why that would be a
problem so we'll have that assurance now
thank you very much today councillor
wing
i'd like to support that i mean i find
it as a as again i'm a new i'm a fairly
new first-time elected councillor
uh and i am that counselor that had two
freedom of information requests rejected
after a polite request for information
in my ward one of which is presently 11
months out of day and
monitoring officers refused to even
answer my email so that is the type of
culture that some some councillors are
operating in i'd also like to state here
and now that early on in our tenure when
when our green leader here trevor trevor
roper was here we got a suspicion that
some of our emails were actually being
intercepted and this was confirmed and
i'm quite happy with that email has been
passed
to make accusations like that without
presenting facts here at this council
isn't going to read a quote from the
email i'm sorry no can you tell this and
that officer then checks the contents of
the email i will pass that email on this
is the culture that we are having to
operate as as elected members as well so
i welcome that the leaders uh widening
of the of the uh monitoring officers the
independent monitor officers scope thank
you
i'm a bit disappointed by that counselor
wing
right councillor yes did you wish to
come back in
um yeah just following on from uh what
the leader has said um i'm happy to
withdraw that proposal for an amendment
thank you
thank you very much councillor yes
do i have any other speakers
no we don't well i propose we go ahead
with voting for acceptance of the report
this evening we've got both
recommendations and any action to
vote in favor or against or abstain from
yeah yes i've just been minded that in
actual counselor ashby in her
presentation did present the case for
regular updates to council and that will
be included as part of our agreement for
the recommendations council piper did
you want to come back in
thank you mr chairman uh just um for
some clarity really um we're about to
vote and i'm sure we're all
of a mind to
accept the recommendations part two says
what if any action to take in response
to these recommendations i'm not quite
sure apart from
a general agreement that we would give
the independent monitoring officer a
complete free reign to guide us and lead
us
quite apart from that i'm not quite sure
that we are in a position to say what
action
we will take um so do we need a
a simple sentence which is at least an
action to begin with that then leads us
on to further actions as they may become
necessary as the independent monitoring
officer does
uh their
work thank you
yes cancel the pipe i rather feel that
would follow necessarily and quite
naturally from the work that the
independent monitoring officer would
undertake nevertheless i turned to
missile manga for advice
um yes we have given you uh
recommendations it's your implementation
that you uh you need to do next uh
you've voted for action i think the next
stage is getting into a detailed action
plan of quite what those breaking it
right down so that you all have clarity
about what those actions are and the
time frame you're going to do those in
and that's the sort of piece that we
will be really monitoring you on you
will want to be sure amongst yourselves
that you think that the actions are
appropriate for the recommendations we
have made
thank you very much indeed mr armanka
can i move to a vote therefore casa
ashby you want to come back in
thank you chair can i request a
recording vote please
of course yes
we are
receiving the recorded vote for
recommendations be accepted and the
action proposed accepted
those in favor of acceptance of the
report
thank you very much chair i'll just read
out everybody's names and if you would
kindly say whether you're in favor of
the recommendations in the report
um with council ashby's slight amendment
about doing regular updates to council
um you're against or you abstain
okay is that all right so uh councillor
alban
four
counselor ara
councillor ashby for
councillor austin for
councillor bailey
for
duckworth
for
councillor everett
council of parents
or
councillor fellows
councillor
ghana four
councillor gregory
four
councillor heart
councillor hopkinson
councillor liz
councillor pat moore
for
councillor paul moore
for
[Music]
councillor ovindon
councillor parsons
councillor linda piper
councillor stuart piper
councillor rattigan
councillor roth four
councillor rogers
councillor roseki
four
councillor david saunders
councillor maeve saunders
councillor savage
four
councillor scoby
[Music]
councillor scott
councillor schrub
councillor tomlinson
councillor towning
[Music]
councillor wallin
councillor whitehead
four
councillor wing
councillor right
and councillor yates
that's unanimous chair
that is unanimous members
that therefore concludes the business of
the meeting of the council this evening
thank you very much indeed